let us have a moment of silence for
Pigeon man the second greatest depiction
of pigeon love since home alone 2. well
episode 4 of The Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon has arrived with tons of zombies
and a surprisingly short lineup to visit
the Eiffel Tower so come with me as we
take a deep dive into the episode and
stick around till the end where we do
some trailer sleuthing to see just what
might be in store in the weeks ahead but
before we begin make sure to like And
subscribe so I can retire and start my
own pigeon Farm the title of this
episode is La Dam de Fair which
translates to The Iron Lady and is the
nickname of the Eiffel Tower something
which is featured prominently in the
episode but before we get there we have
this super odd intro which has to be
some sort of Flash Forward I think I
mean it's possible it could be some type
of dream since the next scene after this
is Daryl regaining Consciousness from
falling through that roof but let's
entertain the idea it's a Flash Forward
the first thing we'll notice is that
Daryl and Laurel have somehow split up
and when Daryl sees him about to be
eaten by a group of zombies he's amazed
when they simply walk past him while the
writers will have you believe his
praying is what saved him I tend to
think he has some sort of immunity that
makes him safe from the Walkers remember
his mother turned into a zombie while
giving birth so it's possible some sort
of antibodies or biological resistance
was created which offers him protection
whether or not Daryl will now believe
Lauren is the second coming remains to
be seen but hey if I saw that I
definitely think something about Laurent
is different Laurel however walks away
from Daryl this pretty much goes against
how the writers have been building his
character this nice empathetic boy now
you could argue Laurent still holds a
grudge against Daryl for leaving him
behind in Paris but I think there's
something more here when your life's on
the line you tend to put these grudges
aside so I can't help but think
something really bad happens between the
two after they leave Paris not to
mention there's the question of how they
got split up in the first place or we
can throw all those theories out and
this was all in Daryl's head when he
fell through that roof perhaps it's a
manifestation of his doubt about whether
or not Laurel is truly special the story
then picks up with the Daryl plummeting
through the roof from the end of episode
3. he lands in some sort of sewer or
Canal where you must fight off the worst
of all zombies prune zombies Daryl
survives and finds himself back again on
the streets of Paris I found it really
interesting these shots of Daryl taking
in a cello player and a couple enjoying
breakfast while there are zombies
puttering below it just goes to show you
that no matter how bad things are life
goes on back at the union of Hope's
Paris space Janae interrogates Sonia the
woman Lauren comforted last episode like
Daryl Janae doesn't believe luhall is
this child destined to save Humanity
rather that this is all a foolish tall
tale to give desperate people hope Janae
calls this false hope a disease and
orders kudzuong who is already looking
for Daryl to pick up Laurel as well now
she never says what she'll do with
Laurent but it doesn't sound so good
when she says he he must be quote rooted
out and if the scene couldn't get any
creepier she soothes one of the babies
in her mind Janae doesn't think of
herself as this evil woman she sees
herself as a protector and part of that
protection is shielding people from
false hope cool zombie Mona Lisa
graffiti as Daryl finds help from the
pigeon man who knows the way to
Isabelle's apartment his love for the
pigeons is too much and ends up getting
himself killed but Daryl is sure to make
quick work of these pigeon-hating
baddies as janae's soldiers stormed the
Union's base last episode Daryl told
Isabel to wait for him at her apartment
a place they visited briefly to get
those sweet sweet drugs in The Fray
Laurent was lost and he doesn't really
know Paris that well so the two surmise
that he's made his way to the Eiffel
Tower that's the place he dreamed of
visiting and held a special place in his
mother's heart Quinn seems pretty down
in the dumps last episode he said that
he was Raul's father but I'm finding
this very unconvincing when he hears
that laurent's life could be in danger
he doesn't seem to care at all in fact
the only reason he wants Laurens to gain
leverage so he can have Isabel in
Isabelle's flashback he knew Lily was
pregnant and still wanted to leave her
something you'd probably not want to do
if you knew it was your child all of
this Laurel stuff seems to be a ploy to
get at Isabel something I think Anna
Quinn's current lover picks up on I
think this is part of why she ultimately
lets Lauren go with Daryl even after she
was told to keep him there at the base
of the Eiffel Tower Laurent takes in the
Majesty of what was once one of the
world's most iconic buildings I love how
there's this huge barricade around it
suggesting there may have been some big
battle here whether to protect people or
this structure itself is unknown last
episode we learned that a military
copter crashed into it hence the
destroyed top later LaRon will tell Anna
that he will one day see it rebuilt to
its former glory but before that day can
come we have hordes of zombies pour out
an attack with Daryl and Isabelle doing
their best to protect LeRon before he's
scooped up by a bunch of Quinn's men now
I thought it a bit weird that this
zombie lunges and attacks are wrong in
the intro if we do take it to be a Flash
Forward we saw how the zombies ignored
him so does it mean that this moment
calls into question that Laurent is
somehow immune it could mean either a
something happens to the wrong between
now and that moment we saw at the
beginning something which grants him
immunity or B this was simply an
oversight by the writers who wanted to
add a little excitement in the scene but
again toss this out if the beginning
wasn't to Flash Forward Daryl and
Isabelle interrogate one of the men who
tried to capture Laro amen by the name
of Armand a name which means Soldier
doesn't take long for Isabel to find out
he's one of Quinn's men but our mald
isn't that Cooperative this is when
Daryl tells a morbid story of a kid
named Jimmy having to kill a piglet the
moral being that sometimes we do things
we think won't cause pain only end up
causing more in the long run Isabel will
later ask Daryl if this kid was actually
him he says it isn't but I don't buy it
it's a pretty elaborate tale to make up
on the spot and both Jimmy and Daryl
share similarities like having a brother
an alcoholic and use of father and the
likelihood that Daryl was picked on for
being weak remember that it was his
brother Merle that raised him to be
tough Daryl ends up stabbing this dude
multiple times and I have no idea how he
was able to walk around after that this
is enough pain for our mom to tell them
of a secret entrance into Quinn's Club
the plan is to create a distraction at
the front entrance while Daryl sneaks in
the back and rescues Laurent meanwhile
Quinn negotiates with Janae in exchange
for Daryl she'll give him Monet's famous
painting of a Japanese Footbridge but
when Janae asks him if he has the kid
Quinn lies that's because he needs the
kid in order to get what he really wants
Isabel Anna also feels slighted because
she was the one who told Quinn that
Laurent would likely be at the Eiffel
Tower and they could trade him to Janae
for a reward I'm sure this greatly
contributed to Anna's decision to let
Daryl and Laurent go never piss off a
French woman there's also this cute
little Side Story featuring Sylvie and
her budding love affair with Emil by the
end of the episode she has chosen to
stay behind with him and he faces a
serious injury sustained while attacking
the club with the help of Armand who
later tries to flee but breaks his leg
and Daryl leaves him to die hilarious
Daryl makes it to Laurent Anna lets them
go but there's one more person standing
in their way Daryl must battle Quinn if
they're going to get out the two duke it
out and Daryl ends up Victorious now
Daryl could have killed Quinn here but
doesn't perhaps he doesn't want to scar
larole by killing his alleged father in
front of him but I don't think this is
the last we'll see of Quinn Isabelle
says in order to get LaRon past janae's
men who have now started to block off
the city they'll need a man with
influence thus she decides to stay back
with Quinn just how she plans on using
him while Daryl and laurently Via boat
isn't clear but as we'll get into my
trailer sleuthing section we'll see some
very interesting developments as Daryl
and Laurent boat down this end Isabelle
arrives back at the club to join a
roughed up Quinn he's not gonna be too
happy when he finds out she wants to
help the man who beat him up and the boy
who escaped but Isabel says Quinn will
do anything for her further down the
river we see a replica of the Statue of
Liberty this is an actual replica you
can visit in Paris and is one quarter
the size of the one in New York it was
given to Paris as a gift by the American
Community to commemorate the Centennial
of the French Revolution no doubt this
is a symbol of Home freedom and hope for
Daryl now we get into our trailer
sleuthing section where we theorize what
might happen in the weeks ahead and we
have another week of not knowing what
happened to Daryl on that tanker but
just a reminder we will get some sort of
flashback to how Daryl got there and
ended up exploding the research facility
on board Daryl and Laurel continued down
the river where Daryl asks about the
nest from Aslan the boat operator he
says it's a special place a home for the
soul meanwhile Isabel's in this large
Mansion surrounded by Quinn's men Quinn
wants to know how long it'll be before
she'll be able to see him differently
but the trailer wants us to believe
she's preparing to kill him remember she
said she would only try to escape once
she knew Laurent was safe Aslan the boat
operator tells Daryl to get the to the
nest suggesting something bad has
happened to him with shots of Daryl and
Laurel on land it appears something
either happens to their boat or the way
up North can't be reached by water I've
been really curious about this shot of
Laurel and Isabelle where Isabelle is
seen wearing fancy jewelry well it looks
from this shot that Isabelle and Quinn
are at some sort of fancy event a fancy
event run by or featuring Janae with the
next shot being of a tranked zombie I
wonder if Janae is showing off the
latest developments of her scientific
experiments and the final episodes will
undoubtedly highlight the deeper
connection made between Daryl and
laurale Daryl will end up giving him his
knife and the two share a deep Embrace
after something very tragic has happened
honestly I don't know how they're gonna
tie all this stuff up in two more
episodes IMDB is saying the first season
is only six apps which means there's a
lot of plot to get to but what are you
thinking of The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon
so far I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching please make sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very much